[Musique]
vingt ans tout rond après les premiers
exploits de samy naceri et frédéric
diefenthal face aux groupes de l'audio
cris de l'audio cru d'air onze ans après
taxi 4
une semaine après sa sortie en salles
taxi 5 est enfin dans le sert comme quoi
c'est souvent une question de patience
dans la vie le producteur luc besson a
confié les clés à franck gastambide qui
succède à gérard pirès et gérard
krawczyk gastambide joue aussi le
premier rôle aux côtés de malik bentalha
tu le retrouves après pattaya frédéric
vous étiez clio des premiers taxis de
certains de certains premiers
le premier nom mais il y avait d'autres
moments parfois des éclats qui pouvait
arriver dans ceux qui ont suivi
là ce qui est intéressant c'est qu'en
fait on a un acteur gastambide on a un
personnage parisien qui va à marseille
est en fait l'initiation de ce parisien
a marseille c'est presque l'initiation
d'un personnage à la saga taxi à
l'imaginaire de taxi ce qui est
intéressant c'est aussi ça nous raconte
quelque chose à mon sens de des
changements qui se sont opérés en france
de ce site allemand idéologiquement nue
en une vingtaine d'années parce que ça à
20 ans le premier taxi dans le premier
taxi
on avait un flic tout mou qui arrivait
pas à mener une enquête et qui se
faisait aider par un taxi marseillais
qui visait mais mon pauvre vieux c'est
ça la vie regarde c'est ça la faconde
marseillaise et puis t'as rien compris
et les institutions on va les mettre par
terre et bal à celle inverse
on a un flic parisien qui arrive à
marseille qui à dire ouh là là moi je
vais vous remettre tous à décrire ça va
bien se passer et ça nous dit beaucoup
de le regard qu'on porte aujourd'hui sur
les institutions et de et de plein de
choses va vous avez reconnu qu'ils
cotisent
j'aime beaucoup le cinéma de gastambide
en réalité moi c'est vrai que pattaya
les cailleras c'était des films des
comédies populaires très assumé qui
jouait aussi avec les codes du comedy de
des comédies américaines gastambide
c'est un amoureux des farrelly da pato
et là on pense évidemment en gardant
taxi audio dans dom bdom beurre etc
sauf que malheureusement le
ça ne prend pas quoi la magie de marche
malik bentalha et très très bien dans le
film de dans l'immédiat ces mendiantes
c'est que je trouve que tout patine un
petit peu on a fait un timide quand même
patrick faure sénateur alors taxer non
mais non ce qui est dommage c'est que
moi aussi l'humour potache de gastambide
j'aime beaucoup et tout le casting
pourrait vraiment un genre est devant
nous des boys à la française
il ne leur dit c'est quand même dingue
parce que c'est laid cccc des gens avec
qui il a l'habitude de travailler et il
ne leur donne pas suffisamment de
matière ben attia et des salons sont
venus à nous non plus à balader sens que
vous parliez de taxi n'ont heureusement
si vous êtes vous êtes vraiment fidèle à
vous même c'est à dire oh dieu j'en peux
plus
et je me tourne mal j'ai vu tourner vers
le public dominique vers le public
qu'est ce que vous avez pensé taxi 5
vous j'ai vu l'avant première officielle
à paris bravo à vos débuts j'ai eu mal a
du mal à rentrer dedans et après parce
qu'on n'oublie pas qu'il ya du jeune
thalia sabine la série il ya marion
cotillard donc on les a toujours quand
même oui en tête et finalement au bout
de dix ont un quart du film on rentre
vraiment dedans on se dit ça y est ils
s'ennuient approprié pour quoi ils sont
pas rentrés dans le jeu je pense que
c'est un peu logique par rapport à leur
concept mais ressent que voilà c'est
tout il faut qu'ils cherchent la petite
bête donc là c'est un film simple il est
simplement fait pour la famille pour
toutes les familles ce que je
reprocherais un petit peu c'est que
c'est un peu scatologique c'est vrai
c'est vrai j'ai pris de sévères coupes à
être sévère c'est vrai qu'il aurait pu
s'en passer
les scènes de vomi bon c'est vrai aussi
qu'on aurait pu s'en passer
donc ça fait partie du personnage voilà
c'est tout point barre mais il faut
reconnaître il faut reconnaître que on
passe un bon moment qu'il a dépoussiéré
le disant l'image le 3 était pas
extraordinaires sont le reconnaître
leucate il y avait sabine inséré qui
était en mouvement
donc je me fais comprendre
mais donc il n'y aurait que c'était pas
facile de reprendre cette saga
cette franchise et il l'a pas trop mal
reprise sincèrement voilà merci mais
j'aimerais remercier dominique ce que je
souhaiterais tu rigoles à evian salvo
taxi ça oui mais vous dites me prouvez
moi
dites moi vous n'avez pas rit pas une
fois mais les gens rien les gens rient
énormément les gens viennent en famille
j'avais des gens qui étaient avec leur
soeur le relent fils et c'est marrant
parce que vraiment les ya une espèce
d'ambiance où les gens applaudissent à
la fin d'une scène est certaine le
spectacle appelle le lait les maris bah
oui il est adrian ri devant bernard
farcy
par principe on attendait un genre de
police academy 2.0 ou un fast and
furious à la french d'ailleurs saga qui
devient de plus en plus comiques aussi
eh ben je trouve pas qu'on aime merci à
vous merci dominique merci à tous taxi
somme de franck gastambide c'est au
cinéma en ce moment allez-y en taxi ou à
bicyclette